Here, Sachin, how are you?
Hi, Shashank. Thanks, Sanya.
I'm good too. Great to see you. You're looking very sharp today. Yeah, last week Anand told me like you were not well. I hope you are back in your health. Everything is fine now.
Thanks, Shashank.
Yeah, thanks, Shashank. I'm recovering, still not fully there, but yeah, last week was really bad, man. I was out for a few days because it just had this chest infection and it just, you know, debilitated me a bit, yeah, yeah. But thanks so much, Shashank, feeling a bit better. Yeah, it's setting down a bit, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
I can understand.
Okay.
Is Anand going to join or he is kind of busy with other things?
Oh, he should join. He should join shortly. Just, I'll just ping him quickly.
Yeah.
And how are the things going on your end?
Yeah, okay, others. Shashank, just been really busy. You know, we have a couple new clients that are, you know, sort of we preparing to take on now at the moment, so yeah, it's a bit a bit of a busy, busy period, and then we've had one or two guys on leave as well, so you know, server side has been more hectic with with less less people, so...
Just.
Been trying to just, you know, juggle a few of those things, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, so in that case, you can take help from After Hours team as well. You can ask Kaila or Manish to lend you one or two resources for a couple of hours, and I guess that should work.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, correct.
Yeah, but others have been good on your positive.
Going good, nothing major. We had one leadership training this Tuesday and Wednesday, so it was...
Yeah, yeah.
Rodge.
Abe.
It hectic because it was, you can say, like it started at 1 A.m. EST. Yeah, it was in Indian time, so we were doing it in day, but yes, those two days were hectic in this week, we are feeling low of energy because the schedule and everything got.
Ohh, OK.
Yeah, it's been hectic. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
change for the entire week. But yes, but eventually I would say this is worth it. Like, it's a great leadership training. Hey, Anand, great to see you.
Yeah, definitely, yeah, yeah.
Hey, how's it going there? Yeah, I like my eyes.
Yeah, how are you?
Mm.
Yep, so, so far so good. Can be better than this. Thank you.
How great, great to hear that. Okay, I was just talking to Vishal and letting him know like we had one leadership training done this week on Tuesday and Wednesday. So it was a bit hectic for us.
No.
Mm.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, because the training started at 1 A.m. EST, not during business hours. Yeah, yeah, so that was a bit hectic, but yeah, overall it was good and everything. Yeah, let me share my screen. Let's agenda stays the same, no change for Nora I.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice.
See, she has been performing well. Her matrix are going up, so that's good. And she has been transitioning from working on access ticket to more technical tickets. So that's one thing that I see. And last month as well, she was training other techs to handle access related tickets. So that's good. Like she is.
learning new things and then giving training. So that's a good thing that I see from her perspective. Overall, things have been going with her well. And she said like it would be good if you can do a weekly connect with me just for five, 10 minutes just to check in and everything. So I said it's okay, not any. I'll talk to him and like he can definitely spend 15 minutes.
For you to connect with me, yeah, that's it. So, after this call, I, as soon as the Collins, I will do attendant connect, just hi, hello, and nothing major with that, but overall, how she has been doing on the technical side.
Yeah.
How?
Mm.
Mhm.
Yep.
Akshay.
She has been doing great, but I expect more engagement on her side on other issues, because you know we want a car route a way for her to excel her technical skills. For that, she needs to be ready to take.
new challenges, of course. So this is our expectation and, you know, for her own growth as well.
Okay.
Yes, correct.
So so far, I've been giving her phishing emails and then MFA, but we want to see more towards on the server side, right, and then the firewall side. So it's just, of course, you know, we want to take those baby steps.
Okay.
Not you know something that I want to bombard her on the technical challenges, so I think the plan is in place and she's doing awesome, but this is this is what I expect.
Correct.
Yeah.
Correct, correct.
Yeah, right. Because, yeah, because you know that how things work in IT, right? Once you become a king, you raise others as kings, right? So with that mindset, I want her to step on to that level where she can do justice to herself and of course to the business.
They totally agree with you.
Correct.
Yeah, so just a follow-up question on this. Is she kind of hesitating or she's not able to action or you haven't given her because she is kind of just getting familiar with the current work that she has got?
Yeah, I think she's initially, you know, people struggle, right? Everybody falls their first time when you even learn how to bike cycle, right? So I think that's what she's dealing with now, which is okay. It's not surprising or it's not...
Correct.
Okay.
You know, uh, causing a trouble as far as our relationship is concerned with ITBD and with Nora, um, so...
I want to let her time to learn.
and technologies, you know, but since you're the manager, you know, I want to loop you in that this is what we have planned for her and this is where we want to see her next. So with that mindset, we'll be engaging her on other technical portions too. Yeah, and then another thing I needed to
Rick.
Correct.
talk to her about planning her day, you know, which is like once she signs into the shift, she needs to plan her tasks, the tickets, you know, not the last minute rush, which I think she has been struggling with in the recent past. So I think that's something she can.
Okay.
Work on.
Okay, I got it. Self-board reviews and ensuring like all the tickets do have a scheduled time. So I know that that's not an issue. I'll teach her. So that's I'll talk to her after this call and explain her how she needs to do it.
Yeah.
because I guess in Access, it's not like that. And maybe the reason behind she's struggling is because she was working on Access, where she could work on anything. And just a little bit of, I would say, a coaching or guidance is needed for her, but I know she will do well on that.
Mm.
Yeah.
That's it, yeah. Yeah, yeah. I know she's, yeah, she's doing awesome. She's doing great, but I need you to loop in and so that it falls under your radar and you're fully aware of it, yeah.
So, I'll talk to her on that.
Correct.
Yeah, and I know you and Rashin have been super busy, so I can be then extending helping hands so that I am able to guide her and coach her. So based on this, I would discuss two things, like how to do self-board reviews in the start of the day, and after every ticket that you handle, you need to just refresh your, that's one thing.
Great.
Perfect.
Third thing is time entries, although I know she's correct in that, I'll still give her guidance because early access now it's real.
Mm.
So she needs to do better. She's not doing that, but she just needs to maintain that. And how do we manage call and tickets at the same time? Because she would be taking calls as well and then she would be getting tickets as well. And I know and we understand that we cannot handle all the tickets at the same time.
Kaila.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And if a customer has, if you have 10 tickets, so you need to learn how to prioritize the tickets by reading. So after every call, you need to refresh your board and see if you have any new tickets. Okay, this is a new ticket. Do I need to action it now or can I do it up to two hours?
Absolutely.
So I'll explain her all these steps. And from a technical standpoint, I think she has got, she would definitely take her time because from almost 10 years, she has been working on access. And when a change comes, we as human beings are a bit resistant and we take some time. So I take your feedback on that.
Yeah.
Mm.
I'll work along with her on that.
Yeah.
And I think you touched that point, Shashank, very well. So when the tickets fall in, we need to prioritize what we can schedule after two hours and what our immediate need, right? So you said it wisely. That's what I was trying to emphasize on, right?
So, and also, yeah, go ahead.
And I know.
Sorry, please go ahead.
Yeah, so another thing I want to know if ITBD has, you know, some knowledge checks which you guys perform for the members, like every month or every quarter, where you evaluate people on their technical capabilities, and if you identify any...
areas of improvement, then you send them for training. Do we have any concept?
As of now, no, but we do at the end of the year where they say that they are ready for the next level, then we have.
That level of grade and process where in they need to give a tech into this, but yes, what I can do, because this is a request from your end, I can get that schedule, where in our technical trainer can gauge her on the technical skills, and maybe I can gauge her on technical skills, and then...
Hmm.
Mm.
Yeah.
work along with you to get that time for her and then schedule technical trainings. As of now, have you identified any key area in which you think she needs to do training? Any area which you have identified?
Mm.
I think.
Yeah, I think we did speak about this, Shashank, and I sent you the list of items, right? So those are pretty much it. And I'm not just limiting myself and you just to, you know, just for L1s or NORA specifically.
Correct.
This is something the, this is something what we expect on all overall the L1s that we get from ITBD. We want to do the regular checks, you know, on their technical skills. And then if we identify any gaps, we want to train them, right, so that they can be well prepared to handle clients.
Yu.
would demand more technical in-depth rate.
And, and to be honest, Anil, from technical standpoint of view, I, and I'll be very honest with you, from any ICT, I haven't seen any anyone sharing this feedback, and you sharing Noora's feedback, I totally get it because she started as a tech who had just to do onboardings and outboardings.
Yeah.
Mm.
Hmm.
And now she is moving into the technical role. So what I will do, as of now, I haven't got any feedback for any engineer, but I'll tell you one thing. There is one dispatcher in Kyle's team, or you can say in Manu's team, Harsh Kant. He is an ITBD resource. So we did that for him, where we assessed him for two.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Mm.
Technical, and then we got his technical team schedule, then.
Yeah, and after that, I would review him once, and if he is filled.
Mm.
Then he would move into after our team and then we'll add one more toucher. So this is one thing that we did because we thought like his level had been great and he can move as a technician. So that's there, but we haven't received any technical feedback for any of the engineers where we see.
Yeah.
So that's one thing that I would say, but yes, point taken. If we definitely receive any feedback, we'll try and do these trainings because none of the takes are getting lagged behind in technical part.
Mm.
Okay, great.
Yeah.
Point taken, that's a valid and fair point, Anand. And we'll implement the same if we'll try, if we'll listen to such kind of feedbacks from any other ISC. And I'll do one more thing. I'll ask specifically the ISC if they see any gap or if they see any challenge.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Mm.
with any of the engineers aligned with them in terms of technical. I'll do this activity with all the SGMs in my next month call. So I'll see where the challenges we face and then we can do a quarterly check with all the engineers and then.
Sure.
Train them accordingly.
Perfect. Thank you.
Thanks and thanks for sharing this feedback. This is a great step that we can do for not only with F2 but all the engineers overall. So I'll get that some checks in place wherein we are doing this. So I'll share this with ITBD management so that.
Mhm.
we can put check in place for all the dedicated side engineers. And this is really a great idea.
Mm.
All right.
Thank you.
Yeah, and thanks for that. So I'll definitely work with Nora on this. You would see a better performance from her because we know that she is.
Yeah.
Sure.
is self-capable, she keeps a check on her tickets, she does not need to be reminded on handling the tickets, but it's just that prioritization is missing. I'll coach her and should not be an issue. Apart from this, any other thing you want to share on it?
Hmm.
Perfect.
No, I think rest all good, yeah.
Okay, and Rishin had a call with Vishal yesterday, so Vishal explained me like Rishin said like 2 to 4 weeks he need because he's interviewing locally as well. So we do not have any issue. We'll wait for that. We'll wait till the end of the May in that case.
Ohh.
Yeah, yep.
Yeah.
Mm.
Perfect.
Kour.
Okay.
Shashank, just some feedback from my side, just to add on to Anil's side, right? Would Nora, we know she needs some time for, you know, to transition fully into this full system analyst role, right? So this is the most critical time for us to support her now, you know, because it's going to go one of two ways. She's either not going to like it.
Yeah.
Correct.
You know, if we put too much pressure too quickly, and that's going to cause more resistance and more errors and more impact, you know, for her, and we don't want to lose her as a resource, let's put it that way, just because she's more comfortable with access, right, type thing. So super important that we support her now.
Okay.
Yeah.
to sort of, you know, hold her hand a little bit if we need to, just to just to give her the time to transition into this, right? But her responsibility is very important in the sense of she has to be willing to go on this journey with us, right? So she can see that her future, her skills are increasing, right? Which makes her more marketable in whatever she does in the future.
right? It helps us, you know, from that point, but it's helping her to grow, right? And with that growth, we don't want resistance. We don't want resistance in the sense of when we give you a task, you know, you now get angry or you get, you know, sort of you're not responding in the right way, you know, and then
Yeah.
Mm.
It leads to, you know, your task falling behind, for example.
So we want the proactiveness and not as always had to continue with this. So whatever she was doing on Access, she needs to continue with that mindset, right, with this transition. Because my expectation for her, you know, at the IST level, is that she can switch between things quite quickly.
Mm.
Yeah.
Right? She, if she needs help, she reaches out to Anil first and then myself, if Anil is not available, to help her to reprioritize if we need to. If she's finding difficulties with prioritization of which tasks to do first, because obviously with access it was two to three days, so it was always different to where now we have a one-hour SLA where we got to acknowledge the client and we got to...
Correct.
Mick.
Good.
respond to them with a solution, you know, as well. So the pressure is much more elevated, right? And then now she's taking calls as well from time to time. So, you know, it's like switching and pivoting between a lot of things. So it's always keeping in mind that these are my most urgent tasks, you know, and where she's having issues, then she needs to reach out so Anil can support her.
Mm.
Kip.
Correct.
And guide her as to which one to do first, but we needed to sort of practice that and get into that mindset of always looking at her tickets, always reviewing, always seeing where she needs to follow up with clients, because that on the service level, and in terms of our service level agreements.
Perfect.
Thanks.
Super, super critical for the KPIs, you know, so we just, so we just wanted to, you know, to continue in that way, yeah, yeah.
Correct, and...
Yeah, and Sachin, I would let you know one thing. I have been working with her for more than a year, and I would definitely say she would not be resistant. She always seeks feedback from me. How am I doing? Did you get any feedback? And all those things.
And.
Mm.
Yeah.
And after the calls, I share the specific feedbacks with her, whatever feedback you give, good or bad or anything. And she's very receptive to that. So she always wants to grow. She has that mindset. So it's not like she is very comfortable in access and wants to do that work.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Mm.
Only she wants to go because she has already communicated that I want to grow. I let me know what I need to do next. Since she had been doing the access, she maybe she does not know the prioritization with relevant coaching and everything. I think she would be able to do well. I think she.
Go ahead, yeah.
Mm.
Ohh.
Yeah.
She gets the gist of how the things work.
So I guess that would not be an issue. So I, and again, with Nora, I know she's super receptive. So any feedback that we give, she works on that very diligently. So, and.
Ohh.
Mm.
Yeah. Yeah, I think the key is to support this, Shashank, you know, because for us right now, it's sort of she's transitioning and she's learning, right? And while she's learning, we're giving her specific tasks. We're not giving her all of the different types of tasks right now. Anil is filtering it based on, as she gets stronger in this, then slowly release the next one and, you know,
Correct.
always difficult to transition, so we got to give her that space to transition. And she needs to feel that our support is there, right? That's why, for me, that's the most important. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mm.
Correct.
Just believe me.
Believe me, I never put a pressure because I know when we put pressure unnecessarily, engineers do break down. And I do not want, because she has been an excellent resource, I do not want to put her in, I would say, bad books of
Mm.
Yeah, yeah.
anyone because she has been doing it.
Yeah.
In terms of overall feedback we have received in quarter one, I just wanted to share this. I have nominated her for R&R for quarter one. So we are uplifting her in all the possible ways and you won't face any challenges with her.
Prince.
Yes.
That's awesome.
she would, you would say like she would feel down or something like that. It will be totally supportive in that case. I know how things do change, like if any partner is giving feedback, some of the managers do take it negatively or something like that. But believe me, I know you guys have been super supportive and.
Yeah.
Mm.
This is a transition journey, so I totally understand we need to support her.
Yeah.
Cool, awesome. Thanks for that, Shashank. And then just on, you know, the skills thing, I just wanted to let you guys know, you know, from ITBD side, that, you know, I think you guys are aware that we have a new GM, right, in British Columbia, that's taken over from Mike Lazier, right? So,
Aarti.
Yes.
With the new GM coming in, there's a key focus on certifications, Shashank. So for our, so we're doing, I'm doing a skills development plan right now for all of our techs and resources with Anil, working closely with Anil, so that we can see how we're going to progress this team further.
Mm.
Okay.
and upscale them on certain things, where after all, we're saying, this is like a minimum standard for our techs to have, right? So we're working on that plan at the moment, right? But from a system analyst point of view, Shashank, some of the key things that we are looking at was definitely, you know, like the MS 900, which is the Microsoft fundamentals.
Correct.
The.
and the AZ-900 as well, at least as a base that we want all of our system analysts to have so that they have that overall sort of understanding. So on your training plan, I think if Nora doesn't have that at this stage, maybe consider, you know, pushing her towards working towards that.
Correct.
I.
Right, because that would be a good starting point, you know, for this sort of skills development that we that we want to go and to get our guys certified, you know, in the right way on the key things, right? So, we're looking at that, and then the follow-up thing at a later stage, once that's been done, is we want to get...
Correct.
Sure.
Yeah.
Get her also on to the WatchGuard training as well, because you know, as F2 of WatchGuard is one of our core products that we use, so the expectation at some stage is that all of our technicians will be certified in WatchGuard, right? At the moment, we're focusing our first batch on our infrastructure techs.
Correct.
Ohh.
Kip.
because that's like, you know, sort of a mandatory requirement for them. But our next stage after our infrastructure techs are completed is to now get our system analyst to also do this training and to be able to get WatchGuard certified at least. So, yeah, yeah.
Yes, and I know like a couple of our engineers which are who are aligned with different ICs, they they are also doing this training. Orion, they have completed both the text from ITBD, then the next one was Phoenix.
Yes.
Yeah.
Awesome.
One of the techs got trained, so I know about that, like this training is ongoing, so yeah, I'll thanks for this and Rishin with the with the new GM, do we is he planning on a timeline like this needs to be done within?
Yes, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so.
two months or three months? Is there a timeline switched right?
Mm.
Yeah, so for us, Shashank, what we doing is we actually preparing that plan now, right, between Anil and myself, because we can't push everyone into training altogether, right, because we need to still support our clients. So what we're doing right now is I'm working with that sort of skills development plan for the entire team.
Okay.
Rick.
And then also to Danil and figure out, you know, which dates, which trainings and that type of thing. And then where Nora fits in that training schedule, right? And then we'll give you the months that we're targeting for her to be trained, where we'll give her dedicated time and stuff. And then we're hoping that you can then put that into her plan.
You know, and then be able to push that, you know, forward with the...
As we said, for the initial ones, for how it's going to be more on the, you know, MS 900 sort of Microsoft fundamentals than Azure, but we'll plan it with you, Shashank, as well, so that you know it aligns on your side as well. But those ones, we're expecting the resources to do it on their own, right? There's no, like the WatchGuard one, you know,
Yeah.
Correct.
will be like a F12 thing and stuff, that's different, yeah. But the, you know, Azure Fundamentals and Microsoft Fundamentals, we sort of, we want them to plan it, prepare, we'll give them the time in between, and then, you know, they write the certification, and then we get this, you know, certified based on that, yeah. So that would be the plan.
That's that's difficult, yeah.
Sure.
Right.
you know, from your side, if you want to start planning towards that, we happy for you to continue, you know, in the background. And then, you know, if you have some tentative dates and stuff, then let us know and we can work that into our plan. But if you prefer us to come back to you with sort of dates and stuff, then we can also do that, you know.
No, I was just asking about MS 900 and AZ 900. Do you have a timeline like this should be completed within?
on the entire thing, yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So I think for us, at least we want, you know, one, if not both, to be completed by, I would say, the end of the year to early next year, right? So at least we want one to be done within like 3 months. You know, and the reason for it is because, you know, they're working, right?
Ohh, I was thinking.
I was thinking like you would say one month within the next two months.
Oh no, I don't think we can put that under pressure, Sushant. The only reason why is because of our workloads, right? Because, you know, we have so many techs and stuff, so we're trying to schedule so that Anil is not impacted where there's two or three techs all at once trying to write the exams and stuff, you know, and then we are debilitated. So the whole idea behind it is we're trying to put these windows in for like months where...
Okay.
I understand.
Good.
Certain texts will then get allocated time, and then Anil will be able to plan around that, you know, on our service things and work, so, so that's why, yeah, it's sort of extended, yeah.
Sure.
What?
And then, to be honest, because Nora is upgrading herself technically, and M.S. 900, she should be able to crack it easily, because she is, yeah, so what I will focus with her is within the next six months, within the next three months, M.S. 900, within the next six months.
Mm.
Yeah.
Just working with that, yes, yeah.
Yeah, is it Nana? That's perfect, that's perfect.
8900 because these are so by end of this year she should complete both of those trainings and again.
Yeah.
grade herself technically so that within the next two or three months, so that she is able to handle all type of technical tickets, not even senior level, but at a system analyst level, she should be able to handle all tickets. And I'm pretty sure like she should be able to do it.
Correct.
Yeah.
Mmh.
I would just keep a plan of MS 900 for the next two to three months. I'll let her know. And then once she completes that, once she gets the certification, so, and these, all the requests that we come in for certification, that these things would be built to F12.
Mm.
Yeah, yeah.
Correct.
Yeah, I think it will be. I can confirm that with our PND as well, Shashank. Yeah, yeah.
This.
Yu.
Yeah, because, like, security team for, and just give me a moment.
Mm.
Yeah.
For Andrea Akshay and Abhijeet, they clearly said like they want him to complete C sub plus. So these two guys completed and after reimbursed it. Similarly for Voyager, they asked one Azure training to be completed for Ankur Bhattacharjee. So they already said like this would be reimbursed. So.
Right.
Mm.
Yeah.
Right, no problem, yeah, yeah, so process is there, it's OK, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What we'll do, we'll first...
Yeah, so I'll get those approvals and everything once it's required. So once she completes her certification, she can then put in a reimbursement and we'll get that process. So not an issue on that side, on the process side. Although, and thanks for such a good conversation because most...
Yeah.
Cool.
Mostly, you know that data, so...
Yes.
utilization has been a bit low in March, but because she was training and everything, that's why her utilization was a bit less. But the good thing that I saw is the number of tickets she crossed at 200 barrier because she's now getting technical tickets on which she is working. They take less time as compared to access, so that's why 200 for her is.
Okay.
Yeah.
Mm.
Ohh.
good number that I see. CSAT again is 100% over 9 surveys. So that's also increasing. Attendance is going good. Not much leaves that we see. There was one unplanned on 30th March, but because of her health issues, nothing major. And her health is going good.
So that's good. Nothing major apart from this. So, and thanks for all the open feedback and discussion. This really helps us to align Nora in getting the right space and on her growth as well.
What I would say, I would envision Nora in next, at least in next 2 1/2 years or three years to be an L2 with Abdur. That's what I envision.
Yeah, and I think that's our sort of, you know, progress, Shashank, as well. You know, it's the internal, you know, mentorship and guidance and stuff, so that, you know, when the opportunity arises, we want to push our guys that are here into those higher roles, right? So that's the...
Yep.
Correct.
you know, for us, that's the value to strengthen the team and then get someone at a junior level coming in for the entry level. So that's always our vision, right? And you know, when I spoke to Vishal yesterday as well, my vision is always, you know, two, three steps ahead of what value these resources are going to be, how interested are they.
To be able to take this on and to be able to grow with us, right? So, that is always key, and those are the types of resources we want to keep and pull, and you know, be able to, yeah.
Correct.
And I'll tell you definitely, one of those resources, she's after my life to get a level upgrade completed and everything. So she definitely wants growth. She's working on it. We have seen like she is dedicated and everything, no issues. It's just a small transition that we have seen and I know she would be able to do well.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
She just needs a small guidance, so need not worry, and Anil, I'll work with you next week, most probably Friday, helping you and see if you see an improvement in a prioritization and everything.
Sure, definitely. Thank you.
Okay, yeah.
Abby.
Thanks, Anand. Thanks, Sachin. Thanks for such open and honest feedback.
Awesome. Thanks, Shashank. We appreciate it. Yeah, we appreciate your efforts as well. Thanks so much. Cool.
Yep.
Thank you so much. Thanks. Have a great day.
All right, say my hello to Mark.
Be a user.
Yeah, he actually left because Abhijeet, as I was talking about, he, while moving down the stairs, he twisted his ankle and he fell. So Aamir took him to hospital. Thankfully, no fracture, just a muscle rupture. So he should be back on Monday. As of now, Abhijeet is resting. So
Yeah.
Okay.
Ohh, sure.
Ohh.
Okay.
Mark did move out a bit early because he had to travel to hospital and everything. But yes, everything under control, no major thing. Yeah. I'll say your hello to Mark on Monday.
Mm.
Okay, okay. No worries. Great. All right, you have a nice weekend, my friend.
Girls.
Thanks so much, Shashank. You keep up. Have a good one. Cheers. Bye.